Mexico has been on a lot of people's
minds as protests continue for the 43
missing students from the IOT Napa
school the students were taken by a drug
cartel with the help of local government
and police and may have been killed
what's become all too clear is that the
line between narco trafficking and
government is gone and that the drug war
has failed everyone agrees on this from
pundits to former presidents everyone of
course except for us and Mexican
government officials who continue to
push drug war policies but if the drug
war is being lost and hundreds of
thousands of people have been killed
then why does it continue
well that's because someone is winning
and it's important to find out who first
you've got Mexican drug cartels like
Sinaloa los zetas and the Gulf Cartel
they rake in six point six billion
dollars a year in drug sold to the US
alone the former head of the Sinaloa
cartel was actually on Forbes --is 2013
list of most powerful people up there
with Bill Gates Forbes lists his source
of income as drug trafficking and calls
him quote self-made that's one way to
put it
beyond the cartels themselves you've got
banks see if you're a drug kingpin at
some point you've got to launder your
money to make it legit
and over the years HSBC Wachovia and
Bank of America to name a few have all
helped cartels do just that
HSBC knowingly turned a blind eye to the
Sinaloa cartel that was laundering money
through its banks and yet it did
purposefully widen some of its bank
teller windows to accommodate such large
amounts of cash then Wachovia actually
accepted four hundred and twenty billion
dollars from suspect Mexican sources
without even bothering to check where it
was coming from for all this and more
no one has spent a day in jail then you
have weapons dealers cartels need
weapons and
most manufacturers are delivering 70% of
all weapons were covered by the Mexican
police between 2007 and 2011 could be
traced back to the us drugs going one
way weapons going the other other
winners of the drug war are police
forces and private security contractors
see there's this thing called the Medina
initiative or plan Mexico which was
signed into law in 2008 by George W Bush
it's essentially a security agreement
between the US and Mexico to fight narco
trafficking and since 2008 Mexico has
received billions of dollars in u.s.
police equipment and security deals
being private prisons also benefit from
an endless drug war in the u.s. almost
half of all federal inmates are in on
drug offenses and increasingly they're
being kept in private prisons and the
laws seem designed to feed the system in
Florida for example having up to 20
grams of marijuana is a criminal
misdemeanor it's you $1,000 fine and
could wind you up in jail for a year
it's good business if you run a private
prison the Corrections Corporation of
America for example made 300 million
dollars in profit just last year finally
there's big business critics of the
Merida Initiative point to Plan Colombia
under Plan Colombia the u.s. promised to
reduce cocaine production in Colombia by
50% in six years instead production went
up however a success story according to
Don Paley who wrote this book drug war
capitalism is that 52 economic reforms
were passed in Colombia that happened to
benefit multinational corporations paly
and others say the middie that
initiative like Plan Colombia is just as
much about helping business as it is
about fighting drugs and there you have
it most people fear the drug war while
some actually turn a profit off of it
and Mexicans for one are saying enough
is enough
who are these billion-dollar cartels
that are operating in the United States
local police in the state of Guerrero
arrested the student
and handed them over to a drug cartel